do you feel like for any kids who are
listening from your city from your state
that are watching this do you think it's
a smart play for them to you know get
out of the comfort zone and maybe yeah
but only when you get booming in mass
you still got to get booming in mass
conquer home first yeah
you still got to be played on the launch
pad with e double and chevy tub
you still gotta you got to be known if
your name isn't no when i left
massachusetts at least 75 percent of the
whole [ __ ] state knew my name you
know what i mean you had already done
what you could do again like if you
don't know me you may be a freshman in
college going to one of these schools
and you from iowa or something but like
blue collar massachusetts people knew i
was so i got to that level and then i
moved
and i feel like even like
like like being moved when she got the
deal with pharrell so if you get a deal
and you gotta move or something but
yeah i feel like you should move out of
mass after you after you conquer it you
know what i mean